[Aplausos]
[Música]
hong kong año 2003 una epidemia causada
por un virus nuevo y desconocido azota
la ex colonia británica causando 1750
contagios y 286 fallecidos un virus que
tuvo una tasa de letalidad en la ciudad
de más del 16% hablamos por supuesto del
corona virus sars el hermano rebelde
pero mucho menos escurridizo que el
actual sars con una virus 2 y claro como
ya os podéis imaginar por aquella época
las noticias habrían seguían y cerraban
consar sars y más sabes
[Música]
lo que nadie podía imaginarse es que 17
años después la ciudad de los
rascacielos por excelencia iba a estar
inmersa no en una sino en dos nuevas
pandemias mundiales de nuevos arts
coronavirus 2 y la del totalitarismo de
xi jinping y es precisamente de esta
segunda especie de pandemia de la que
hoy os vamos a hablar aquí en visual
político
[Música]
el caso amigos es que aunque pueda
resultarnos sorprendente lo que hoy más
le preocupa a los hongkoneses no es
lakovic 19 sino el intrusismo de pekín
es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado en
varios vídeos pero la situación es tan
particular y avanza tan rápido que aquí
estamos de nuevo
si durante el 2019 hong kong fue noticia
por las numerosas protestas que se
desataron tras el intento de pekín de
imponer una ley de extradición que le
permitiera llevar a china ante los
tribunales del partido comunista a
cuantos hongkoneses quisiera el régimen
de xi jinping lo que ahora se les viene
encima en 2020 puede ser mucho peor si
no pretende poner en funcionamiento lo
antes posible la conocida como ley de
seguridad nacional una ley que vuelve a
poner sobre la mesa cuestiones como la
extradición y el intervencionismo chino
en el sistema judicial de hong kong un
sistema que supuestamente debería
funcionar de forma totalmente libre e
independiente hasta al menos el año 2047
eso es lo que pactó china con el reino
unido- cuando se acordó la transferencia
de soberanía de hong kong
en este vídeo os vamos a hablar no solo
de la ley de seguridad nacional que xi
jinping quiere imponer en hong kong una
ley que ha vuelto a hacer estallar las
calles de esta ciudad sino también sobre
como los tentáculos de china son cada
vez más largos
nos acompañáis en este pequeño viaje por
las garras internacionales del régimen
chino con origen en hong kong pues
empecemos
hong kong la última gran batalla
amigos amigas de visual politics y bien
hong kong debería ser hasta 2047 un
territorio administrado de forma
autónoma con sus propias leyes su propio
sistema judicial y sus propias normas
sociales y económicas hay pequeños
flecos que se dejaron abiertos en 1997
y es que veréis en ese año cuando los
británicos transfirieron a china la
soberanía de su entonces colonia en ese
momento entró en vigor una especie de
mini constitución propia llamada ley
básica un texto llamado a garantizar
todas esas libertades y que pekín se
comprometía a salvaguardar durante al
menos 50 años todo pintaba muy bien sin
embargo como suele pasar en estos casos
hecha la ley hecha la trampa
[Música]
tiene que aplicar la ley de seguridad
nacional en base al propio artículo 23
de la ley básica de hong kong un
artículo que dice lo siguiente la región
administrativa especial de hong kong
promulgar a leyes por sí misma para
prohibir cualquier acto de tradición
secesión sedición subversión contra el
gobierno popular central o robo de
secretos de estado para prohibir que
organizaciones u organismos políticos
extranjeros realicen actividades
políticas en la región y para prohibir
que organizaciones políticas u
organismos de la región establezcan
vínculos con organizaciones u organismos
políticos extranjeros artículo 23 de la
ley básica como veis este artículo es
básicamente una salvaguarda para el
régimen chino es un artículo que tiene
como fin evitar que el régimen especial
de libertades que tiene hong kong se
pueda convertir en un elemento
desestabilizador para la propia china o
en una amenaza a la unidad nacional pues
bien el problema es que el hong kong
autónomo no ha tenido nunca una
legislación de seguridad nacional hubo
un intento si en el 2003 de impulsar la
creación de este marco legal pero las
protestas multitudinarias que se
desencadenaron consiguieron frenarlo
ahora vuelve a estar sobre la mesa
claro que llegamos a este punto puede
que te estés preguntando a ver pero
entonces por qué tanto lío si en
realidad es algo que dice el propio
artículo 23 de la ley básica pues amigos
la clave está en las palabras la región
especial de hong kong promulgarán ley es
por sí misma que recoge este artículo 23
el problema simple y llanamente es que
el nuevo plan de pekín pasa por saltarse
ese pequeño detalle
de esta forma la ley de seguridad
nacional preparada por china sería
añadida directamente en el anexo 3º de
la ley básica el anexo que recoge la
legislación del gobierno central de
pekín que es aplicable en el territorio
de hong kong es decir en otras palabras
esta normativa de seguridad nacional no
sería propuesta y aprobada por los
órganos políticos de hong kong sino que
vendría hecha e impuesta desde arriba
algo que viola claramente el artículo 23
[Música]
es decir todo un golpe de estado y claro
este cambio esta adicción esta nueva ley
permitiría entre otras cosas que
cualquier persona a la que pekín
considerara como rebelde disidente
activista o simplemente opositor
político puede ser juzgada directamente
por los tribunales del régimen chino
tribunales que por supuesto no tienen
nada de independiente si están sometidos
al propio partido comunista de china
y eso es lo que explica que otra vez las
calles de hong kong hayan explotado
protestas disturbios detenciones y en
esta ocasión incluso amenazas militares
el ejército chino dice que está
preparado para proteger la seguridad en
hong kong a medida que las protestas
crecen el comandante de lepe le dice que
10.000 tropas están preparadas para
salvaguardar la soberanía de la ciudad
mientras pekín avisa de no subestimar a
china ahora bien porque siempre ha
elegido precisamente este momento para
meter con calzador esta legislación
[Música]
pues no no pensáis ni por un instante
que ha sido algo casual la pandemia del
coronavirus puede haber tenido mucho que
ver con el momento elegido por el líder
chino y es que the disciplines está
intentando utilizar la pandemia de
coronavirus como una especie de arma
para combatir las protestas protestas
que el propio gobierno chino sabía
perfectamente que si van a producir en
cuanto anunciase en sus intenciones para
hong kong como pues utilizando la
prohibición de reuniones de más de ocho
personas que aún está en vigor en hong
kong como medida de distanciamiento
social para evitar la propagación del
virus una vía que el gobierno títere de
carril am en hong kong ha aprovechado
para ilegalizar todas y cada una de las
manifestaciones en contra de la
aplicación de esta ley en nombre por
supuesto de la salud pública
veis el juego el momento es
maquiavélicamente perfecto
por un lado la amenaza de el coronavirus
les da a los dirigentes chinos o mejor
dicho a sus títeres en hong kong la
posibilidad de arrestar
discrecionalmente a todo aquel que se
atreva a salir a la calle para protestar
contra una medida que al fin y al cabo
cambiará hong kong y la vida de sus
habitantes para siempre mucho antes
además de lo que se había estipulado
[Aplausos]
por otra parte el mundo está tan
preocupado y centrado en combatir la
pandemia y sus consecuencias económicas
que esta crisis de libertades en hong
kong puede que no tenga tanta
repercusión y justo aquí es cuando
muchos os preguntaréis pero se puede
hacer algo al respecto
pues bien lo cierto es que parece
complicados y sin fin no quiere esperar
sabe que no va a tener una oportunidad
mejor para llevar a cabo su plan de
hacerse con el control total sobre hong
kong esperar 27 años no va a ser que no
sin embargo a pesar de todo algunos
países ya están planteándose mover
fichas en caso de que se aplique
finalmente esta medida pero lo cierto es
que su capacidad para actuar es muy
limitada por ejemplo eeuu un país con
una relación comercial de 66 mil
millones de dólares anuales con hong
kong y un sinfín de intereses
empresariales es el país al que más le
podría afectar esta cuestión muchas
inversiones se paralizarían y muchas
empresas saldrían de la ciudad debido a
la inseguridad jurídica y social lo que
dañaría sustancialmente esa buena
relación comercial por eso y porque es
todo un escándalo político ver a cámara
lenta como una dictadura como la china
se hace con el control de uno de los
lugares tradicionalmente más libres y es
por lo que washington ha elevado el tono
de sus amenazas
efe
en cangas
es nuevo
amenazas que hoy por hoy a pekín le
entran por un lado y le salen por el
otro
tal vez el país que más capacidad
tendría para actuar contra esta acción
de china sería precisamente el reino
unido- la ex metrópoli podría mermar la
capacidad de pekín para controlar a los
con con ese sí por ejemplo decidiera
otorgar la condición de nacionales
británicos de ultramar también a los
hongkoneses nacidos después de la
entrega de la colonia china en 1997 esto
es por así decirlo un tipo de
nacionalidad británica de segunda clase
que se le otorgó a los hongkoneses
nacidos antes de 1997 y que les da
derecho a un pasaporte británico pero no
por ejemplo a vivir o trabajar en el
reino unido
[Música]
aún así el escenario parece muy pero que
muy complicado y todo apunta a que
estamos presenciando paso a paso los
últimos instantes de libertad de hong
kong
amigos seamos honestos salvo que un
milagro los remedios estamos asistiendo
al dar toman de hong kong ahora bien si
pensáis que las garras más autoritarias
de xi jinping se limitan a ir contra
esta ciudad estáis muy pero que muy
equivocados lo cierto es que las
injerencias de pekín en el exterior
tanto en materia de espionaje como de
represión a la disidencia han aumentado
enormemente desde que siguen pin se hizo
con el poder supremo en 2013
los tentáculos de la influencia china si
hay un país en el mundo que entiende
perfectamente lo que está viviendo el
pueblo de hong kong ese es el lugar a
dudas' taiwán el país insular en la isla
de formosa ha sufrido desde hace décadas
los embates del régimen chino que no les
reconoce como país sino como parte de
china envites que durante los últimos
años y con el creciente posicionamiento
de china como epicentro mundial de la
producción industrial y el crecimiento
económico se han vuelto cada vez más
fuertes las elecciones de taiwán se
quitan después de las declaraciones de
un supuesto espía chino wang detuvo a
dos ejecutivos chinos bajo acusaciones
de influencia a las elecciones y propuso
una ley anti infiltración después de las
confesiones de guandique ya os lo
contamos ya en un reciente vídeo que os
dejamos por aquí arriba china intentó
influir en las elecciones de taiwán de
enero para evitar que el actual y
reelegida presidenta soberanista sign
went volviera a ganar
[Música]
y si uanl y ya no fue uno de los
encargados de hacerlo moviéndose por el
país con un pasaporte surcoreano falso
hablamos de un antiguo espía que sirvió
a los servicios de inteligencia del
partido comunista de china desde el 2014
y que estaba especializado en asuntos de
hong kong y taiwán ahora tras desertar
vive exiliado en australia y desde allí
ha dado muchos detalles sobre el
creciente alcance de los tentáculos
chinos en las instituciones y empresas
de muchos países instituciones por
ejemplo como las universidades ellos los
estudiantes pro régimen chino se han
infiltrado en todas las universidades
incluyendo asociaciones de estudiantes y
otros grupos estudiantiles y organismos
algunos de los estudiantes de la china
continental si se les dan algunos
favores beneficios y oportunidades
estarían dispuestos a trabajar para
nosotros wang lijian ex espía chino
confeso amigos el gobierno chino está
aprendiendo a toda velocidad a moverse
como pez en el agua en ese mundo de
sombras que se mueve a través de la
inteligencia los infiltrados y los
sobornos
las reformas chinas de los últimos 40
años junto a su despegue y apertura
económica han tenido un efecto muy
positivo no sólo para cientos de
millones de chinos sino prácticamente
para todos los habitantes de la tierra
es algo que os hemos contado ya mil
veces
sin embargo desgraciadamente conchi
jinping está creciendo una china más
nacionalista y que da pasos atrás en lo
que respecta a libertades civiles la
falta de respeto a la legalidad vigente
en hong kong y sus intentos de
intromisión política en una democracia
consolidada como taiwán son buena prueba
de ello
desde visual política queremos trasladar
todo nuestro apoyo al pueblo de hong
kong que lucha por no perder su libertad
y ahora ahora que hago una pregunta como
ves este creciente papel autoritario y
político de china crees que debemos
preocuparnos por contra piensas que será
algo pasajero y no podrá interrumpir los
avances aperturistas que lleva china
experimentando desde hace cuatro décadas
déjanos tu respuesta aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like i suscribiros
abisal político un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]